Welcome to Google Developers
Weekly for November 25, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the world
of Google Developers on the set
and off.
It was an incredible week for
developers here at Google.
So let's get right to it,
and we'll start with Glass.
Timothy Jordan, never seen
without his trademark hat,
gave us a sneak peek of the
brand new Glass Development
Kit.
The GDK lets us glimpse the
future of cool apps on Glass.
Also last week, we hosted
the Chrome Dev Summit,
an incredible two-day
web platform experience.
This event featured an
overwhelming 12 plus hours
of presentations on Dart, Blink,
Page Speed, PNaCl, and more.
If you missed anything, we
have it archived for you.
And if that wasn't
enough, Colt McAnlis
teamed up with the TimesOpen
team from the New York Times
to talk about tuning
websites and mobile apps
for performance.
You have a need for speed,
and so do your users.
And we've all seen the headlines
about large-scale password
leaks.
Breno de Medeiros
and Tim Bray, who
are not excited
about this trend,
talk about best practices
and raw survival
on how to keep your accounts
and information safe.
And Drive and Gmail are
getting closer together.
Steve Bazyl highlights
the new integration
of Gmail attachments
and Drive and what
this means for developers
on your Drive apps.
But Drive isn't the only Google
app getting new features.
Jonathan Simon
walks us through how
you can set up and use a
Google Cloud SQL instance.
This event covers
creating a database
and connecting to it, setting
up PHP pages, and much more.
If your app is up in the clouds,
make sure you watch this video.
We then welcome back
YouTuber Ikai Lan
from New York as
he tells us where
to go for all the latest
information on our Java API
client libraries.
Whether you use Maven or
Gradle, Ikai has your answers.
And we're celebrating the half
birthday of Google Play games.
But you're getting the gift.
Todd Kerpelman is giving
everybody updated SDKs.
So watch this event
for all the fun.
And every year at
this time, the days
get very short or very long,
depending on where you live.
And Google Code-in gets going.
Pre-university students can
sign up for Google Code-in
and work on real world
open-source software projects,
learn a lot, and
even win prizes,
including a trip
to the Googleplex.
Check out the program
site to find out more.
Also, the Google
Civic Information API
got an important upgrade
for US users this week.
Now you can write apps
that connect users
to their local
elected government,
all the way down to
municipal officials.
And our newest Chrome
experiment, "A Journey Through
Middle-earth,"
launched this week.
It's an interactive
experience for "Hobbit" fans.
And for mobile web
developers, it's
a great demonstration of what's
possible on mobile devices
using HTML5 and technologies
like the Touch Events API, Web
Audio API, and Media Queries.
And SPDY, S-P-D-Y, is
our experimental protocol
for making the web faster,
and it's doing a great job.
This week we published
results showing
that SPDY has dramatically
reduced latency
in Google's major
web applications,
and the SPDY work continues.
And to make sure you never
miss a thing, speedy or slow,
from the world of
Google Developers,
subscribe to the Google
Developers on YouTube and check
out the GDL schedule at
developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.